conf
secretary President Biden refusing to
talk about the Scandal that could have
put American lives in danger defense
secretary Lloyd Austin facing calls to
resign after keeping both Biden and
Senior officials in the dark on his
recent hospitalization for three whole
days America's defense secretary went
awal with two Wars raging in Ukraine and
Israel that's because he was secretly in
the ICU after complications following
elective surgery Austin's second in
command was put in charge while she was
on vacation in Puerto Rico but even she
didn't know that her boss was in the
hospital according to Politico one DOD
official was told by Austin's AIDs that
the secret AR was quote working from
home for the week and the Pentagon now
claims it didn't give an update about
Austin because his chief of staff had
the flu thankfully Austin is no longer
in the ICU but he remains in the
hospital but so far it looks like he
will face no consequences for his
deception I want to make sure I put a
fork in my answer to you there is no U
uh no plan
or anything other than for secretary
Austin to stay in the job and continuing
the leadership that he's been ex that
he's been
demonstrating the New York Post pointing
out a critical question on the Scandal
quote how could President Biden not
notice his defense secretary was
missing an outrage continues to grow and
it's not just Republicans who were upset
if this Administration would conceal a
mere elective minor surgery for a
cabinet secretary what might be what
might they be concealing about Joe
Biden's Health this was not an
appropriate step not an appropriate way
to handle what uh was his
hospitalization we're at a time of a lot
of turmoil internationally and suddenly
had the Secretary of Defense more than
just a matter of wasn't there actually
sent over false information saying I'm
working from home when he's not actually
available at all it is possible that his
health condition or his medical
condition uh clouded his Judgment at
that time that could have been the
reason why he decided not to to notify
people as he should have that said it's
clear that the system broke
down you know Dana we all wish the
defense secretary well and hope that he
is recuperating but it wasn't just three
days he also underwent surgery on
December 22nd and according to a former
Chief of Staff for the Department of
Defense the wh house Situation Room
keeps track in real time of the
whereabouts of all senior officials
including key cabinet secretaries and
there's never a time when the secretary
truly goes off the grid now it seems
given where we are in the world that
this guy should not be off the grid for
more than 10 seconds right he's sixth in
line to the presidency um I felt like
this could have been a vep episode if we
still had that show around and I wish we
did but the the real life situation one
and some ways you're like it's so
baffling it's almost hilarious but it's
also extremely serious so as
fellow Democrats of him has said well it
was an extreme lack of judgment okay and
it was Reckless what about our allies
well it's not like it's been a quiet
time for the US military in the past few
weeks you've had our troops being
attacked in the Middle East you've had a
possible Suez canel Crisis you've had a
situation where you have the action
taken by the United States to kill an
iranian-backed militia man in Baghdad
while he is not able to respond now they
say the chain of command says that
sencom had the had the opportunity if
they found it to go ahead and strike but
this is the other thing I would say for
President Biden this is so insulting to
him and if he lets it stand I think he's
making a huge mistake uh he is in a
position right now where his
administration is being questioned on
competence and this shows that there is
no competence they haven't had a cabinet
meeting since October 2nd I don't know
if any of them talked to each other
meanwhile you have the Secretary of
State running all around the world
trying to prevent the war from widening
and he needs the cover of the defense
secretary he has no idea that anybody is
that is out and I feel like I don't like
it when people say he should be fired
but I do think if Biden allows him to
stay that's another lack of judgment
because it's just too serious to let it
go you know Jesse what Dana says is is
absolutely true I mean everyone is
starting to worry about what's going on
in the Biden Administration who's
running it from the beginning we kept
saying who's running it but when you
think about our adversaries you think
about xiin ping and you think about uh
you know Putin they're saying you know
this guy's had surgery they know they
know what's going on he's he's Mia Biden
doesn't even know he's Mia we can do
whatever we want not fear that they
won't even get their Cavalry around
together
well judge who could forget Robert mn's
rhinoplasty on the E Eve of the Ted
offensive or Donald rumsfeld's lipo
during operation Iraqi Freedom listen I
did not expect an elective surgery
scandal in Biden's cabinet to be with
the defense secretary I was thinking
maybe mayor Pete or perhaps kamla Harris
but I need to know a little bit about
the surgery was it cosmetic was it a
breast reduction or was it something
like lasic because that will definitely
make me a little bit more sympathetic
but you have to tell your boss when
you're undergoing a procedure like when
Greg flew to Germany for the emergency
heightening procedure and he came back
5'7 he just said procedure and we didn't
ask any questions because of HIPPA now
if you're Biden and you're violated that
I'm sorry if you're Biden and you're
summoning everybody to the situation
room and you say all right get me the
Secretary of Defense oh well he's in the
ICU he can't reach well what happened to
the chief of staff can we find out well
the chief of staff is sick with the flu
can I get the deputy up sorry the depu
is on vacation in Puerto Rico and she's
not coming back you're now trying to
maybe ask sticky Sammy to come to the
situation room that's how far down the
totem pole you're going I do now
question Austin's judgment because as
the defense secretary judge you were
supposed to plan for contingencies you
were supposed to plan for worst case
scenarios you war game but he didn't
think that anything could have gone
wrong during a procedure at age 70 so
he's not telling him this what else
isn't he telling the commanderin-chief I
can't imagine what this would have been
like if this had happened during the
Trump Administration this would have
been a constitutional crisis this would
have put all of our national security at
stake this would have been a chain of
command dis I they would have run the
defense secretary out of town by Friday
that's and then they would have gone on
the Sunday shows judge and they would
have said it's time to have the adults
back in the room this is a clown show
you know Greg he is a forar general and
from the Army he would not have
tolerated this from anyone who worked
for him and yet he's not offering up his
resignation and even Biden said he
wouldn't accept it if he did things have
changed in the last couple years this is
part of a I mean it if this were just an
exception it would probably would be a
smaller story but it's part of a greater
mosaic of malfant right every choice
every decision every action has some
kind of opportunity cost and for example
if you fight an unnecessary War those
billions could have gone somewhere else
think of all the intell the the
intellectual effort that goes into that
so we're in this era of massive
opportunity costs because the democrat's
priorities are so far out of whack
instead of focusing on real external
threats they put their eggs in something
else domestic Terror hoaxes Dei and ESG
and the military actually demonizing our
military suggesting and then doing
research that they might actually be
white supremacists in our midst you have
January 6 theater you have troops being
forced to read Marxist literature and
there's a cost in this in the realm of
Defense the chief concern should be
defense protecting the Homeland but that
suffers when you
politicize the military when you put
political and cultural IDE ideas in
front of that you marginalize the
efficiency the deadliness and the
Readiness and the competence of our
military you put feelings over fighting
and you do that when you have two Wars
raging when you have Iran making trouble
you got China being China while other
countries see their Homeland as worthy
of Defense our sees America as the
source of all of our problems and now
you see the cost and this is a small
part of a massive one because this
mindset this mindset is a mistake that
is Upstream from all our other concerns
so it flows down to you know the
competence in corporations leadership in
the military in education uh in culture
basically we we have a manufactured
self-loathing that is undermining
confidence in EV confidence in
everything you know Jessica we're really
involved in a regional War Dana said it
our service members are being attacked
in Iraq and in Syria uh that can
Converge on a World War and we know that
Joe Biden didn't even know until January
I believe it was the 5ifth five days
later that his defense SE defense as
they call it defense SEC yeah SE anyway
was not available I mean who is making
these decisions who's available Chief of
Staff of sick this Deputy is in
vacationing what is going on I everyone
is asking them El that I I haven't heard
from one Democrat or seen one Democrat
who's been asked about this on TV or
otherwise who hasn't been in total shock
and surprise at this especially that the
deputy would not have gone on vacation
right if she knew that this was
happening back right and um it's
extremely disturbing it is in congruous
with a four-star general and just the
way that he grew up and the way that he
served which makes you question whether
there might be something else going on
that's what um John Brennan was saying
in that interview that there's appears
to be a clouded judgment moment um I
don't think that this
reflects some rot within the
administration or the government and I
don't think that the administration
certainly sees these as needless Wars um
they see them as Wars obviously that we
should be involved in and it's important
to protect democracy but at this
critical flux moment and I would
particular struck we're listening to
President Biden today at the Emanuel am
church today giving remarks and he's
interrupted by protesters who want to
talk about Gaza this is an issue that is
eating up our country it is consuming us
and our national Consciousness and
obviously our Consciousness abroad and
you want to know that someone who is in
such an important position of power is
there and if he's not there that you
know why he isn't there and that the
proper line of command is in place I
assume that nothing will change change
in terms of uh a resignation on this
though Friday could come and then we
could have those Sunday shows it can
take a few days for it to unfold and the
Biden Administration was obviously
caught flat-footed by this but he has a
lot of explaining to do and it's a a
critically dangerous moment in history
for this to have happened the
interesting thing is that day that he
had the surgery was December 22nd he
didn't tell anybody about that either he
should have
but what I'm saying my question is you
comment on what brandan is saying
Brennan was saying you know maybe had a
clouded judgment you know he had to go
into the ICU he didn't have a clouded
judgment before he went in for elective
surgery that was that was re Jud Works
yes okay hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so sub subscribe right now